[MONKEY NOISES]
Basically that
means, this is me.
This is Jane.
I left England to go and
study chimpanzees, not just
any animal but the
one most like us.
The DNA of humans
and chimpanzees
differs by only just over 1%.
They use certain plants as
medicine, leaves as sponges.
Each individual has his
or her own personality.
Chimpanzees have the same
kind of emotions as we do.
When the old female, Flow,
died, the older child
kept going back to the
body, pulled the dead hand
towards him, as though
trying to make her groom him.
I saw him climb a
tree and look down
this nest where he and
his mother slept together.
He climbed down, curled
up on the ground,
and he died of grief.
People have said,
well, it's only humans
who have some kind
of spirituality,
but I don't think so.
People need to understand
that chimpanzees
are sentient and sapient
because these chimpanzees had
given me so much.
I knew I had to do something
to conserve their environment.
So I went to Africa
as a scientist.
I left the jungle
as an activist.
In this master class, I'd
like to share with you all
of the amazing things that I
discovered about these closest
relatives of ours.
I want to talk about
what we all can do
together to right the wrongs.
You have an indomitable spirit.
You can make change
in your own life
every single day to make
this a better world.
There is still a window of time.
Nature can win, if
we give her a chance.
I'm Jane Goodall, and
this is my master class.